on gère ça on n'a pas le choix donc j'ai
la chance d'avoir des enfants
extraordinaires
qui essayent de protéger leur maman et
maximum il faut pas oublier aussi les
deux premiers enfants de jean pierre je
suis rennais olivier qui sont aussi
extraordinaire et qu'on est tous soudés
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué parce
que ça présente c'est tout le temps là
j'arrive toujours pas à croire qu'ils
aient qui est parti j'ai toujours
l'impression qu'il va franchir la porte
mais
il a vraiment dire quand on voit les
images pardon
mais je suis très heureuse d'être avec
vous ou nous aussi on est content de te
voir je suis merci de tout le soutien
que vous m'avez donné aussi c'est quoi
les mots que tu as eue nathalie avec
avec les enfants le soir où vous êtes
retrouvés pour la première fois son sang
sont jean pierre qui était de
jean-pierre en hausse et voilà c'était
vraiment c'était le ciment avec voilà de
la famille c'était un incroyable
parce que ce jour que j'ai souvent pensé
à toi et je me suis dit comment elle a
géré ce soir avec voilà et se retrouver
sans jean pierre à la maison c'est un
vide immense qu'est ce tu n'auras dixou
vous êtes dit
mais que c'est surtout mes enfants qui
ont plus parlé que moi ça qui est
impressionnant qui vont du moment on est
là tu n'es pas tout seul on veut
protéger parce que on super ton
supporterait pas de perdre parce que
c'est vrai que
une fois qu'il est parti c'est un peu
compliqué de vivre non je pense à plein
de choses
mais il faut que je me batte pour lui
pas pardon je suis il
faut que je me batte pour lui faut que
je me batte pour les études pour mes
enfants pour qu'ils réussissent leur vie
donc c'est ça qui me donne le punch
parce que je sais que pour lui ses
enfants c'était primordial notion donc
jeu et puis comme vous savez je crois
vraiment à la vie après la mort on va en
parler dans un instant ça parce que
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable ce que
tu vas te dire ça m'aide énormément mais
c'est vrai que mes enfants c'est
vraiment d amour qu'est ce qui t'a dit
jean-pierre ce que vous avez un moment
quand il était
très mal et ce que vous avez une
dernière discussion tous les deux que
vous êtes dit rice souvent ouais c'est
vrai vraiment souvent mais moi j'étais
toujours sans tabou ah ouais vraiment tu
le disais quoi oui moi je disais plein
de choses et puis
on n'est pas immortel mais j'ai toujours
dit qu'il partirait pas d'un cancer et
en fin de compte il est parti d'un avc
massive donc il n'est pas parti du
cancer pour moi